I want to get out the way sorry about
this sir you're blocking the crosswalk
right now so here's a good thing about
me first and foremost I'm a Christian
and what I learned is that Jesus once
Walked on Water
I don't know where I'm going with this
guys hopefully one day The Next Step
will be the Oscars it's about setting
goals and that's you know what I want to
talk to you too too guys please I don't
feel like you have goals because I think
that's why you've been here all the time
like I think if you guys know this was
the goal no no no it can't be listen if
you guys I I'm white so can you explain
to me are you like a travel size Chris
Raw
I want to introduce y'all to the first
white woman who nipples touch right here
God all right I'm gonna go with you
because I know you yes I'm gonna say
your favorite movie Sleepless in Seattle
wow yeah because you like love stories I
do man you're a fan of Tom Hanks
Sleepless in Seattle by the way yeah you
love love stories too yeah yours is two
girls in one cup well that's not a
laughs
I don't think that's
I want to tell you Merry Christmas
and to drink a lot of tea that's one of
the things we sound like
don't I do not get out of my face
Queen
get me some tea it's the angry snowman
with some nutty but uh that's good
that's good right you got a cooking nose
one of your ears is [ __ ] up the top of
the stupid your hairline is [ __ ] up
and one of my ears is done
and your skin complexion makes my balls
itch
you get the [ __ ] out
look at me I'm the rock I'm the biggest
movie
that's enough
they're not supposed to go the joke's
not supposed to go on that long
let's see this is what I gotta deal with
on Jumanji
[Laughter]
a little game that involves a female so
are you good with the ladies am I good
with the ladies am I good with the
ladies why don't you just ask Mariah
[Applause]
when I step here there's a cloud there's
always a cloud over here right you
create that cloud me you bring that
stormy Cloud it's a really negative Dark
Cloud I bring Sunshine we try our best
to lighten it up sunshine she tries her
best I bring something you see we're
trying right yes I just watch they try
their best to hit you with positivity I
know but Stephen this is what is this no
no no I'm a dog I'm a barker Cloud rain
thunder
negative how much money do you have man
like what are you talking about what's
money all right listen you what is money
you fall off tomorrow yes you're good
for the rest of your life what is what
is life what is it like you guys have to
Define what this stuff means it's very
true you know I'm at a point where
honestly I I look at grass and I say wow
wow that makes sense
yeah you probably wouldn't understand
what I'm saying because you guys aren't
at this level of life I'm at a point
where I breathe and I and I laugh
because I say that's that's air you get
what I'm saying my wife and I need alone
time we tell the kids oh we tell the
kids that we're going camping
yeah slang word for
slow down Okay so
now okay
student driving man put your [ __ ]
together driving the car without power
windows is a big mistake I can't do this
all day if you're not stupid this look
then you go
the way that you wear your jeans they're
they're like so fitted they're so small
like whenever you walk it's like a it's
like petite like put together but it's
like something's mysterious about it
there's nothing wrong with the way I
walk
hey Shaq can't ride no horse Feet Don't
touch the ground but you can't be the
dead horse cause dead horses tell no
Tales because they're horses who lost
their tails
oh I mean because you're a fit guy
clearly [ __ ] you're in them
very thick well in Hollywood yes
you don't have to be I consider myself
very fit okay I'm what you call a sex
symbol oh wow
yeah yeah
speaking of family Dwayne you also just
recently bought your mom a house
that like makes me want to cry yeah no
way no no no way I gotta
okay
a billion dollars later you're fine all
right should we clap for that I think
the whole room right now is taking the
same thing
why don't you just admit to the public
into America that you got that from
listening to me because that's what I've
been saying all week well Stephen what
I'm going to admit is that you need the
rest of your mustache back that's what
I'm going to admit okay that's that's
what I'm gonna make it's amazing that
the underdog one yeah well let me tell
you something every dog has his day but
it's night time no time for dogs dogs
are asleep so it's cat top cats come out
tonight freaks come out at night shackle
free
laughs
Central Intelligence I'm shooting my
video well I'm sure he shoot his video
now [ __ ] your video
no you crazy my fans will beat the [ __ ]
out your fans but yo [ __ ] your fans
you've always seen yourself as an action
star action star man I can flip uh I did
I did my own nah he didn't want to do
one stunt I did I did one stunt which
one I did the one I parallel parked that
car by myself uh and uh there was one
scene where I fall out and I hit my head
what are you what are you talking about
like you was in there doing back-to-back
stunts you didn't do any stunts cute I
did all my stuff
Mr XXX himself backed out let me tell
you what oh what old used to be action
mode did he came out tough no no no put
the stunt guys to the side I got it he
did one stunt threw him up against that
wall a little too hard didn't they the
next take Cube was in that chair sipping
coffee I said I said I said what you
doing man they doing the stunt he hurt
my back on the first one
I was a guy that everybody wanted to be
around because I was over was a good
time now will on the other hand now let
me tell you about this now because I
know you know first of all you're
looking at a new version of will since
the teeth he's changed
will be for the Great Wall of teeth was
a different will
that will that Will was a problem you've
had your driver's license taken away a
few times because of some infraction
like no I know I know you're asking me a
serious question I swear to goodness I
was in court today renewing my driver's
license again because it got suspended
I'm a speed demon you're a speed demon
I'm Speed Demon I don't I don't respect
the law and I don't feel like I have to
because I'm I'm a sex symbol now when
you do this when my kid asked me for
help on their homework but I don't know
the answer I usually
say golf
[Applause]
so were you sit in the hot tub your body
ain't that good when you can just walk
around without your shirt off if we're
ever going to talk about bodies I want
you not to be the one to bring that
conversation all right if you don't get
out of here shaped like a bean bag that
got that in you
you get to walk down the street and
people like oh that's Kevin hey what's
up why me I'm bombarded I'm suffocated
you understand what I'm saying I have no
peace of mind people might walk up to
you occasionally and they might want to
just take a picture with you and say
congratulations great work with me
they want to debate my life is harder
well Stephen here's what I want you to
realize
hey you're lying nobody comes up to you
okay Stephen A Smith does not have one
fan not one there's never been a request
for a pitcher there's never been a
request for a debate
you are snaps you're Snap Finger famous
that's the guy that's the what's the guy
what's the guy that's uh what's that
what's the guy that's on the thing nah
they're on the ESPN thing that's what
they do that's actually me they know his
name that's what they do whose idea was
it for the fake pregnancy well I mean
when you're having fake sex then you
have fake babies
yeah well you know what you may have
been having fake sex on your side of the
bed but on my side I was tearing that
how the Marvel [ __ ] up in here
[Applause]
I smell it now you smell it now I smell
it now smell all those Marco [ __ ]
Chris Evans
Captain America Superman and Batman will
slap you right back into the Fantastic
Four you ain't
we will kick your ass right back to
Asgard that's right that's right I
kicked the ass out your guards you
stinky [ __ ] yeah go I got you I think I
think I'm like uh an angel not many
people have achieved what you know I'm
about to set up to achieve whatever
that's neither what I'm saying is I'm
about to make 40 000 people feel better
right you know it was shot bad one shot
oh I hate my life I want to kill myself
Kevin Hart comes no I don't I want to
live you're giving them sand spiders
inspiration oh my goodness Rihanna was
kicked off of Instagram for excessive
nudity people
say something else she's so sexy that I
would honestly pay a million dollars to
see her naked here's the thing I've I've
already seen it and I'm willing to pay
again
I would I would still pay for it hey how
come he didn't play in a celebrity game
this year man oh yeah
what else do you want from me
it's over I can't do it anymore I
achieved greatness Shaq you know what
that feels like Kenny I know you know
what that feels that's yes all right I'm
stopping right there
haha [ __ ] you thought I was juggling
out here doing promo Cube tell them
we're doing promo promo [ __ ] promo
[ __ ] promo [ __ ] promo [ __ ] tell them
again cute you know what we're doing but
you tell them it's better when you tell
me a promo [ __ ] a lot of people here
that I love tonight we got a little pump
we got a little Zan uh these are also
the reasons that your 12 year old cousin
wants a face tattoo stop writing on your
Goddamn face stop writing on your face
it's stupid you're not going to get a
job if this [ __ ] don't work out stop he
doesn't do it to me he doesn't do it to
me he has nothing to say let me finish I
didn't know and then he starts going in
his Soliloquy and it doesn't matter what
he's Soliloquy was not you didn't have
to say solidify right there it didn't
fit but why did you lose it because
that's how I talk
he wakes up and there's somebody that
gives him seven words he has to use in
that day actually I get myself something
Soliloquy was a word that he had to use
today I read the dictionary every day
I'm so sick of you man you dude let me
tell you something you don't you don't
commit himize nothing you want to just
hold on a second there we go I just want
to make sure that you don't fall back
and hit your soft spot man if you don't
get your hand off my [ __ ] head I care
about it man a short stature that does
not mean that I'm a baby
hey huh huh how many keys on that hey
let's tell me how many keys let me see
it man we go
here's the number one rule in Hollywood
don't work with no animals don't work
with no [ __ ] kids I agree I did are
we there yet and they're 10 times more
professional than this one you got you
know what you got another thing coming I
don't know if we could do that
currently I live in Los Angeles I got a
I got a house in Cabo you know another
house in Miami
oh God damn Little Island just brought a
little island yeah that was cool you
know me myself I I like walks long walks
New York I got one in New York
um Philadelphia I got a place in Philly
too
um
jerk [ __ ] Jersey I got one in Jersey too
other than that man I'm just I'm a
regular dude I'm a regular dude we're
nice to meet you I'm just like yeah yeah
so just uh that's a little bit about me
no different from anybody else in here I
wasn't born in Hawaii we lived there in
San Francisco but I did a lot of my
growing up there so yeah so it was it
was amazing I don't know I don't think
no tell me
for years I've always said well when we
were there you gave me a big speech like
this is my land I started
the first time here tell us about
yourself I know you're from Philly yes I
am Jay uh I'm from Philadelphia and uh
I'm a big deal people uh
I don't know yeah yeah
uh you know Jay I'm quite sure you could
tell recently I became a sex symbol yes
you look
um uh besides that modeling gigs are
coming left and right yeah uh Baby Gap
called
um just tons of stuff man like right now
I can honestly say I'm like a kid in a
candy store I'm enjoying life uh I'm
enjoying where I am I'm enjoying my
comedy career so I said let me come here
on your show to tell people about it
educate y'all tell y'all how I'm doing
you know I'm living life right now it's
going well look at me
when we were there he gave me a very
like spiritual speech about how it all
started
thank you
this is a cliff where I was born and my
mother
this is the problem
try to be respectful speaking of
yourself not you said it's hard for you
not to look amazing that's very true
it's very true and I will say you look
fantastic it's like honestly it looks
like somebody drew me it's like perfect
I look like a sketch you look like a big
sketch right yeah a great artist sat
down and Drew and then here you are this
is what I am I'm a sexist in
Philadelphia we're filming Untouchable
okay um and I had a day off so I decided
to go to the sixes game James Harden is
playing in the game in the whole game
the whole first quarter he's just he's
off and I was like you know why you off
because you're in my city your beard
stinks I hate you I was like I hate your
calves I told him I said I think you got
I think you got butt shots I was saying
a bunch of stuff and he got mad he said
he said remember all of this he said I'm
about to cook you I said you gonna cook
me or put me in a pot because I'm ready
see
we're talking like he's I don't even
know why he's paying me this much
attention like and at some point I was
like James is very unprofessional on
your behalf like you're not even
supposed to be talking to me this much
James went on the score 55 points and
here's the bad part they beat us by 30
and with like a minute left he was
dribbling the ball and staying in the
half court and he was just staring at me
Eagles tell your team what you did to
him
I said you keep your mouth shut inside
this
Wayne Johnson don't say it breath smells
like [ __ ] on the regular oh nobody knows
this you don't know where the eyebrow
raise came from it came from the
reaction of people hello and everybody
knows
that's what The Rock is cooking shitty
bread okay don't encourage him my wife
is 100 the fun police like when I'm when
I'm having fun
pull over you're having too much fun
one of the worst things that happened to
me okay uh I'm having like a phenomenal
shoe for those people that play
Blackjack a shoe is uh you know a deck
of cards you're going through it and you
know it's just going great I'm hot and
there's a hand where I get like two
eights and I bet you know I better a
ridiculous amount of money on the hand
and I'm like all right well I gotta
split that you know I'm I'm talking to
myself what does the dealer have uh the
dealer had a sick showing oh I never
forget this uh and I got the two eights
I'm like oh I gotta split that so I
split them and I get another eight and I
was like Hey scared money don't make no
money uh all right all right let's go
I'm so excited I split them hey give me
nope nope split that one too another
eight four eights out there I didn't
split them all at this point little
piece of poop came out my butt at this
point
at this point I'm extremely I'm
extremely nervous because I've never
seen anything like this but it's people
around so I'm trying to play it cool I'm
like hey hey all right okay all right
all right what what now what we got to
do now hit that hit the first one a
three come out the dealer looks at me
she's like you gotta double down I'll
say yeah yeah
I know I know I gotta do that I gotta
double down on that let's go ahead and
double down she said you want to see it
face up or down I said I don't want to
see it
she put it down the next one comes out
it's a two so now I got a ten she goes
oh my God I gotta double it down again
at this point my Palms are sweating at
this point I said I don't want to see it
face down okay the next card comes out I
get a 10 so I got 18 on the last one at
another 10. the dealer had a six showing
okay all right here we go it's go time
the dealer turns over the card
underneath beneath it in slow motion it
was I saw it it was a five I said
you you got to be oh stop oh
not like this not like this
I'm like go slow go slow go slow
dealers you know dealers are fast to the
point where you can't count like you
haven't you ever try to add it up but
you don't know where you're at so so I
know it's a five out there right she had
the five boot real fast it was a three I
was a ho ho ho what was that what's that
she's like are you ready I said no no
count that what is that what is that
okay all right all right you got 14. all
right go slow go slow real fast Ace Ace
oh my God what's going on what you got
15. like slow motion I've never seen
anything like it in my life real fast
what 6 21 she took the money look she
she didn't even look me in the eye she
said
I just sat there I kept counting it I
was like hold on wait wait hold on
11 plus three that's the 14. you got an
Ace Ace that put you all right right
there I think you got the hold on wait a
minute wait a second all right what I
have what are these what what do I have
lift all that up that's nothing this
ain't nothing none of this is nothing
huh
here's what pissed me off there's a guy
behind me he goes man that's crazy ain't
it
I was really bad enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
do we have the clip of Stephen A Smith
hitting a heavy bag when he was working
out boxing uh just roll the clip to
Stephen A Smith throwing some of the
most aggressive uppercuts that I've ever
seen in my life uh dressed like he has
never went to the gym uh Stephen A Smith
as you can see has on a pair of the
loosest gray sweatpants and a uh black
tank top that definitely doesn't fit it
looks like it's been through seven
family reunions and uh and two barbecues
I mean you know your voice is important
but you don't know how important it is
until you lose it because you can't
really communicate and everything comes
off rude like you just look rude like
when you're talking to people
if you become a billionaire what will be
your billionaire Quirk you know some
people like like some are going to space
are you gonna go space you're gonna
drill the sound of the earth what are
you going to do what is what is going to
be your billionaire like because when
people become billionaires they become
they're really weird yeah but those are
those those are those are white
billionaires
um I think uh yeah I mean he uses a lot
of the big words I don't really think he
knows the definition of these words
and great points to make him come off as
an educated man such as yeah uh well
I've heard Steve use words like
Despicable he used it wrong a couple
times he was like uh listen to me skip
you have no despicable timing
it wasn't supposed to be I gotta say
it's like all parents all kids you know
it's it's I don't have anything you
can't help yourself but like your kids
never think you're cool but I bet if
Kevin Hart is your dad then you think
that's cool not cool
you're the exception to that absolutely
I'm cool right there's no question about
it right I actually remind them like I
said you do know how cool your dad is I
I say that too a mess I'm passing the
phone to someone who gets so scared at
junkets at any kind of animals
especially butterflies I'm passing
phones somebody that has no hair but
they have all forehead I'm passing the
phone to someone who will be starring in
his own superhero movie called honky
Pete
I'm passing the phone to somebody that
doesn't wash the back of their knees
[Music]
don't encourage that guys I'm passing
the phone to someone who lost his
virginity when he was
22 years old
I'm passing the phone to somebody that
flips their underwear inside out because
they're too lazy to go wash them
correctly wow
I'm passing the phone back to someone
who wears a thong backwards I'm passing
the phone to somebody that doesn't have
a big toe
I'm passing the phone to someone who's
still trying to find out who his real
father is
I'm passing the phone to somebody that's
been lying about his Hawaiian Heritage
for his whole career
how far would you go to impress your
girlfriend's family I wouldn't go too
far uh you know my thing is if I impress
her you got to go talk to your family
it's a great answer uh I really would go
I probably would go uh a lot further
than he would because I'm actually a
nice guy and I was raised to make
someone feel comfortable being someone's
mother a father but those gang bangers
that's your answer you know we're raised
differently that sounds like a long long
drawn out it's not a drawing I think
it's just I'm just a black guy hi you're
her mother oh my God it's so happy to
meet you you're you must be her dad hi
sir and I will have a title
you're a bully with a capital B you come
here and you bully people with words
that we don't understand half that stuff
ain't even in a dictionary excuse me
that would be him you got to that would
be him that would be him that's not me
I've got nothing on him you're looking
at a player that colossal sizes what
what did you say
look at him he could lost the sizes in
and that makes him a traumatical
disaster station what are you talking
about so wrote a book I didn't write a
book I wrote a good book
[Applause]
I'll just read one of these of many many
quotes here before reading this book I
was an unemployed loser sleeping on my
mom's couch now I'm living the life of
my dreams all thanks to Kevin Hart
written by Kevin Hart professional
athlete yeah
it was from Kevin Hart's somewhat funny
comedian Kevin Hart award-winning actor
and Kevin Hart life coach and ladies man
yeah those are different different
versions of myself that gave the book
I gave the book The just dude how did
you get them to write a blurb for your
book I just had to call the different
versions of myself yeah I'm very good at
going in third person about myself Kevin
Kevin thinks this book is genius
oh oh take my job what you know well all
I gotta do is point to myself and talk
loud and say a bunch of words if it
doesn't make any sense that's all I got
to do let me tell you something skip
okay I'm not going to talk about the
samarity of this man and the severity
their pet peeve got it no this one
what is it smelling his balls right here
that's my pet peeve yeah you do it all
the time we're all set and I'll catch
you in the corner no but it's not a pet
people I enjoy doing that
[Laughter]
I know you know I know when the
streaming doesn't go well when you're
watching uh PornHub yeah well that's
your pet oh that's good word of the day
blow V8
blow V8 you know what blow V8 is what
Steve Smith does on a consistent basis
are you disrespected you just yeah why
you disrespect them you constantly yeah
and I'm sick of it so this is your cake
I'm sick of it oh look at your yapping
you know what I like about the Olympics
so they always changing it up make a
slight change you changed the whole game
like basketball at 3x3 it's a whole
different game completely different game
volleyball at a beach beach volleyball
oh my God tennis at a table
tennis
you see me work I see you working can't
stand there boxing turn up the heat
hot boxing no I'm not I'm not really
sure how that one works recreational
cast and every time I do get wrecked
okay all right I'm picking up what
you're laying down what you're saying is
you basically add a word you change the
sport that's what I'm saying all right
okay like this like uh so you got
mountain biking Mountain Dew biking now
we got sponsors all right Dan Lipton
dead body lifting right that's a little
dark but it's a team sport yeah you see
what I'm saying shooting
right that's a white man's sport no no
no shooting dice now that's for the
community you have an Irish name do I it
couldn't be more Irish because no one
told you that until now you know I think
my mother just liked the name let me
educate you something black people black
people are notorious for picking things
that they saw one day and say that's my
baby name
uh me you know I'm following
the footsteps of of like a Tom Cruise
you know several guys that Tom Cruise
Jackie Chan we're all Cut From the Same
Cloth I know yeah I could see that fire
I guess get that analogy no no no you
Tom Cruise probably the next mission
impossible yeah like stuff like that
like hanging off the plane for him to be
all right something like Tom Cruise is
yeah like
it's very serious people I suffered a
very serious injury this weekend yeah in
Disney World I was with my kids Jay and
I uh I took my kids tubing and I know it
doesn't sound like it's that that's
serious at first but I was on the tube
with my kids and the guy goes hey man
for adults you know we can speed this
thing up right I'm a daredevil you know
that okay I'm a thug Jay uh my
background speaks for itself I've been
to jail listen what I'm saying
so we get off of the tube I'm like yeah
I want to do it so he's got me and my
brother we both get on separate twos
speed boat starts pulling at 70 miles
per hour I'm not lying okay we hit a
wave right now because I'm so small
because of my height I'm aerodynamic not
on purpose not on purpose but we hit the
wave bow I shoot up in the air now I was
scared at first but then in my mind I
started thinking like oh I'm gonna stick
it like I'm gonna come down and people
are watching they're going like oh this
is probably what Kevin Hart does on the
side so I was like okay so I came down
right but I'm staring the tube as I'm
coming down I land now you know water is
water is hard like you know if you hit
it hard it's like concrete so I smack
the water with the tube right I don't
know I'm hurt at the time I hear
everybody on the boat they're like oh my
God Kevin it sounded just like that
they're like
it was like oh my God Kevin
yeah these are all white people on the
boat no no
so
I came down now when I came down I hit
the I hit the tube and I bounced off
into the water I'm thinking I'm still
fine I go to swim like literally with
this stroke I go to take a sweat a
stroke but this Soldier had popped out
of socket I just thought that something
I thought that
like you know I don't know who's had
this okay to show it or not but if it's
okay you literally had you don't have
that much feeling at the bottom so I was
like oh my arm must be caught on the
tube so
that's the only reason it's not coming
back up so so once I saw I couldn't get
it up this is when I started to panic a
little bit I didn't cry but you probably
would have thought that that's what it
was
so like at this point in time I'm
flagging a guy because I want help I'm
like
this this idiot this jackass is giving
me a thumbs up you did it
no no I can't move it they come they get
me out the water and uh my brother was
like oh man he said dude I can see your
shoulder and like you know you're fine
until you see it like once I saw it like
it's just how I remember when you had
your jam toe at that time you remember
right remember you were fine so I was
like Shaq you jammed your toe
it was like
[Applause]
that's not shank cries
it was the same thing it was the same
thing so I saw it I panicked I lied to
you not I passed out like because I saw
my shoulder out the socket he was like
you're gonna be all right and I was like
too late I'm gone
okay it was over I woke up in this
middle it was popped back in